let me go next to um
let's go to adam from irvine california
adam from
irvine what's going on
adam from irvine california can hear
background noise you were on the air
just barely
marginally are you running a buzz saw in
the background
i want to know what you think about
trump's uh
military advisors
are you using an electric shaver right
now
it's my computer was the question about
trump firing military advisors
oh okay listen i'm gonna take it off air
because it's it's that's wild
um listen so trump firing military
advisors there's kind of two questions
one if he's out in nine weeks why is he
firing anybody what difference does it
make
that so that's that's sort of like one
question the other side of it is
is this part of a planned military coup
um i think this is just trump's a
petulant child and he's firing people
who he's been at odds with and he would
have fired the months ago
were it not for somebody saying hey you
know what
um you might want to wait until after
the election i
i perfectly to be perfectly honest i
think it's that simple
i don't think we should read much more
into it and you know there's people
acting like
uh trump's a criminal genius here
staging some coup by replacing mark
esper i
just don't see it i really don't